mankind has always been trying to get to
the bottom of the nature of things
around
us and while there were times when
people used to struggle to define the
laws of classical physics
scientists of the 21st century are busy
solving comparatively more sophisticated
and challenging tasks
thanks to the joint efforts of
scientists of all times
there is an impressive list of
scientific discoveries to mankind's
credit
and now the acquired knowledge allows us
to take a peek at the most mysterious
corners
of the universe today i invite you on a
tour around our closest galaxies
but before reaching those we will stop
the dwarf planet
makimaki and the trans-neptunian object
sadner
talk about the weirdest objects ever to
have approached our earth
venture to the most horrifying
exoplanets and fly by the star known as
wr 102 a great trip is about to begin
let's get started
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
it was pluto that was the first
astronomical body
discovered beyond neptune's orbit it
happened over 90 years ago
back in 1930 unfortunately the
technologies of the day were not
advanced enough to be able to detect
dim objects at large distances that is
why it took another 47 years
before another discovery of a celestial
object in that
area of space had been made in 1978
sharon was discovered and the first
asteroid beyond pluto's orbit
albion was detected in 1992
the 1990s proved to be fruitful in terms
of discovering a string of
transneptunian celestial bodies
but at the beginning of the 21st century
there was a positive boom in exploring
remote parts of the solar system
that is when the prominent team of
researchers michael brown
david rabinowitz and chadwick trujillo
pinpointed the most well-known space
objects
beyond neptune's orbit among these
one designated 2005 fy9
can be singled out later on it was to be
renamed into makimaki
this exoplanet was first seen in images
taken on the 31st of march 2005
and four months later on the 29th of
july
information about the newly discovered
celestial object was made available to
the general public
after the official statement from the
research group
when discovered the planetoid was just
slightly dimmer than pluto
as for its location at the time it was
much higher than the ecliptic plane
in the region of the constellation
comaberanises
thanks to archive images makimaki has
been thoroughly studied by now
the planetoid's eccentricity isn't big
at just
0.162 the angle between the planetoid's
orbit and the ecliptic plane is 29
degrees
which is why this object bright and
large as it is
hadn't been noticed before when
exploring those parts of our system
the first researchers had focused on the
ecliptic plane
as they assumed that the chances of
discovering new celestial bodies there
were higher at the time however the
planetoid was located in the upper part
of its orbit
which is why the researchers couldn't
see it makimaki completes a full orbit
around the system's center every 306
years
it is currently 52.5 astronomical units
away from the sun
the planetoid is going to reach its
aphelion in the year 2033
with a distance to the sun 52.82
astronomical units having receded from
the parent star and reached its furthest
point from it
makimaki will start approaching it the
planetoid is estimated to reach its
perihelion
in the year 2187
with the distance separating it from the
sun being 38 astronomical units at that
point
on the planetoid's closest approach to
the system's center
its luminosity will be almost the same
as that of pluto
which will enable scientists to collect
more accurate data
about it in terms of its orbit's
parameters the dwarf planet
falls into the category of the so-called
classical objects of the kuiper belt
or qbino unlike plutinos which are in
orbital resonance with neptune
qbinos lie quite far from this icy giant
that is why the gravitational influence
exerted by neptune over them is quite
negligible
on the 23rd of april 2011 makimaki's
disc was passing in front of a dim
star in the constellation coma berenices
thanks to this eclipse it was possible
to estimate the planetoid size
rather accurately its equatorial
diameter
measures one and a half thousand
kilometers
its polar diameter on the other hand
turned out to be
one thousand four and kilometers
which is around 62 percent that of pluto
this earns makimaki the status of the
fourth largest transneptunian object
coming after pluto aerys and haumea
however it may still be beaten by gong
gong
whose parameters still haven't been
estimated with a satisfying degree of
accuracy
makimaki's exact mass still remains to
be found out
the planetoid's average density is
estimated at approximately 1.7 grams per
cubic centimeter
which is slightly lower than that of
pluto
this information allows us to gauge the
dwarf planet's mass at roughly 3 times
10 to the power of 21 kilograms
incidentally it is four percent that of
the moon
makimaki's rotation period is around 22
and a half hours
which is quite a lot for a dwarf planet
it is known that the planetoid faces the
earth with its equator
although the tilt of its axis with
respect to the orbital plane
hasn't been estimated yet
makimaki is admittedly a rather bright
object
the average ratio of its actual
brightness equals around 0.8
first spectral analysis revealed that
the planetoid surface is not homogeneous
most of it shows a high brightness ratio
reaching ninety percent
still up to seven percent of the dwarf
planet's surface
is dotted with dark spots absorbing up
to 98 percent of the light shed on it
these patches are thought to be areas of
surface made up of rocks that are
peculiar to the planetoid
strangely enough later observations
carried out using the galileo national
telescope
showed makimaki's surface as rather
homogeneous
the dark spots reportedly seen on it may
have been
areas of observation or reflections of
an unknown satellite
that happened to be passing over the
dwarf planet's surface
that is why further observations are
needed to settle the question
observations and spectral analysis
revealed that makimaki's surface is
almost as bright as that of pluto
it consists for the most part of methane
ethane
and a very small amount of nitrogen
continuous exposure to powerful
ultraviolet rays is thought to have
produced thorolins
complex hydrocarbon polymers containing
nitrogen
it is thorolens that give methane snow
on the surfaces of
objects a typical reddish hue
makimaki's surface temperature is
currently estimated at around 29 kelvin
or 244 degrees celsius below
zero when makimaki is in its perihelion
the temperature slightly rises to around
34 kelvin
or 239 degrees celsius below zero
as the melting point of nitrogen and
methane is much higher
it is logical to assume that the
planetoid must be covered with reddish
snow
made up of methane mixed with ethane
nitrogen and tholins
interestingly observations and estimates
show that methane on makimaki's surface
is crystallized
and appears as rather large grains
around one centimeter in size
as for ethane it looks like grains
measuring around one millimeter in
diameter
and filling smaller crevices and holes
on the planetoid
it goes without saying that in such low
temperatures machumaki's atmosphere is
bound to be extremely rarified
the density of gases just above the
planetoid surface
is approximately one billion times as
low as that on our earth
the eternal ice the surface is encased
in cannot melt even on the planetoid's
closest approach to the sun
[Music]
besides most of the solar energy
reaching the dwarf planet
rebounds back into space on account of
the object's high albedo
for a long time it was thought that
makimaki didn't have any satellites
however in 2015 a group of american
researchers did detect a celestial body
orbiting the planetoid
that's when its main parameters were
gauged the object hasn't been given a
name yet
and for now is officially catalogued as
s 2015
still the satellite was informally
nicknamed mk2
as usual a quick overview of the basic
parameters
to begin with mk2 is a small and dark
celestial body that reflects around
seven percent of all light shed on it
its diameter may measure anything from
90 to 200 kilometers
and the radius of its orbit cannot be
less than 21 000 kilometers
as for its orbital period it is around
12 earth days
the inner makeup of mk2 is thought to be
identical to that of makimaki
however sun rays would have vaporized
the layers of methane snow that used to
cover its surface
besides with almost no gravitation
forces exerted by the satellite to speak
of
the gases molecules would have floated
away into space
it is admittedly an extremely slow
process that takes billions of years to
complete
as makimaki's rotation period is
anomalously long
it gives grounds to assume that there is
at least one more
large satellite orbiting it but it still
remains to be discovered
makimaki is currently located almost to
the furthest point of its orbit
which makes it difficult to investigate
it however
sending out an interplanetary space
probe to explore it
is hardly sensible at this point
estimates show that it will take the
spacecraft
around 16 years to reach the planetoid
even taking into account a gravity boost
maneuver near jupiter
just in 150 years mere
seconds in astronomical terms makimaki
will be closer to us than pluto
even though it will take a while sooner
or later
it will certainly reveal its secrets to
us
in the late 20th century there was a
major breakthrough in studying remote
corners of our solar system
3555 celestial objects have been
discovered beyond neptune's orbit since
the 1990s
most of them are not very large bodies
made up of water ice and frozen gases
like methane
and nitrogen trans-neptunian objects
form conventional areas around the sun
like the kuiper belt
the scattered disk and supposedly the
oort cloud
the kuiper belt encompasses the solar
system as a large ring
at distances from 30 to 55 astronomical
units from the center
it resembles the asteroid belt only it
is 20 times as wide
and up to 200 times as massive the
kuiper belt consists mainly of debris
remaining after the formation of the
solar system
although it does contain rather large
objects as well
like pluto sharon haumea makimaki and
other planetoids
the borders of the scattered disc are
more blurred
it consists of objects whose perihelion
is over 35 astronomical units
and whose orbits are elongated or lie
closely to the ecliptic plane
most of these objects are not very large
and are quite gravitationally
unstable most of the scattered discs
objects orbits are posited to have been
predefined by neptune
with the latter having expelled them
from the inner layers of the solar
system
acting as some kind of a gravitational
cannon
the largest space object in this area in
space
is the planetoid eris there is one more
object worthy of our attention
it's a small planetoid called sedna
that's what we'll talk about today
this dwarf planet was discovered on the
14th of november 2003 by american
astronomers michael brown
chadwick trujillo and david rabinowitz
at the time of discovery it was thought
to be the second largest object of the
kind
beaten only by pluto however very soon
it found itself in the fifth place among
all known transneptunian objects
coming after eris haumea and makimaki
as revealed by calculations of sadness
orbit around the sun
its trajectory is extremely elongated
its perihelion is 76 astronomical units
which is two and a half times the radius
of neptune's average orbit
sedna's aphelion is 942 astronomical
units away from the sun
thus the planetoid must be one of the
remotest and apparently the coldest
objects in our system detected so far
that is actually what has earned it its
name one of its discoveries
michael brown has dubbed it after an
inuit goddess of sea animals
sedna completes a full orbit around the
center of the solar system within
approximately eleven and a half thousand
years
when discovered it was 89.6 astronomical
units away from the sun
this is approximately twice the distance
to pluto
sadly is now on its way to meet the sun
it is expected to reach its perihelion
around the year 2076
however the sun will not be visible as a
disk from the dwarf planet's surface
even from the closest point of its orbit
when watched from sedna our sun will
look like a very bright star
with a luminosity much higher than that
of the moon in our sky
sedna's diameter is about a thousand
kilometers
it is only forty percent that of pluto
and slightly smaller than sharon
unfortunately there are no moons around
sedna that is why it is hardly
possible to gauge its mass with a high
degree of accuracy
as it is it is estimated at one to ten
percent
that of our moon in plain exact numbers
it could be anything from 8.3 times 10
to the power of 20 kilograms
to 7 times 10 to the power of 21
kilograms
only a special expedition to the dwarf
planet's environs would yield much more
precise data
[Music]
sedna's rotation period is about 10
hours with a rotation axis
tilting to the orbital plane at almost
12 degrees
the planetoid's bright red surface
reflects around
32 percent of the light shed on it
spectral analysis shows the dwarf
planet's outer layers are mostly made up
of water ice and frozen gases
methane ethane and nitrogen prolonged
ultraviolet radiation treatment
of the hydrocarbon sludge on the surface
produced
phthalins organic polymers containing
nitrogen
it is these substances that give the
planetoid surface its bright color
sedna will be comparatively close to the
sun for about 200
years in this time its surface
temperature will rise to 35.6
kelvin or 237.6 degrees
celsius below zero this will make some
of the gases shrouding the planetoid
evaporate
which in its turn will greatly rarify
the atmosphere
however the most optimistic estimates
show that its density will be
70 000 times less than that of the earth
at the very least
when the planetoid hits the escape
trajectory from the sun
its temperature will rather dramatically
fall to a few degrees above absolute
zero
it is thought that unlike on triton
pluto and darius
there are no methane snow precipitations
on sedna on account of its low
temperatures
even though sedna was discovered almost
30 years ago
scientists still don't have a unanimous
opinion about it
one of the things on which they don't
agree with each other is where it
belongs
that is whether it is part of the
scattered disk or the oort cloud
[Music]
the oort cloud is a hypothetical area in
the solar system
lying beyond the scattered disc and
stretching for up to a hundred thousand
astronomical units away from the sun
its borders are rather blurred this part
of the solar system
looks like a spherical cloud made up of
a great number of comet nuclei
it is from here that comets with
enormous orbital periods of tens of
thousands of years take off as it were
the hill sphere or the sun's
gravitational sphere of influence
is considered the cloud's outer boundary
the sphere's radius is about one light
year
sedna's orbit is so elongated that as it
travels in the solar system
it traverses the entire area of the
scattered disk
and approaches the inner boundary of the
oort cloud
some scientists believe that the object
is too far from the main planets in the
solar system
and so their gravitational pull is
negligible
besides sedna was estimated never to
have come
close enough to neptune to have had its
orbit in any way affected
these clues lead us to believe that
sedna is much closer to the oort cloud
objects
even though most of its orbit finds
itself within the scattered disk
as sedna is remote and barely studied
there are theories awaiting further
confirmation
for example modeling the process of
radioactive decay
suggests the possibility of there being
a liquid ocean in the planetoid's
interior
calculations of the trajectories of
several transneptunian objects with
elongated orbits
including sedna give grounds to
believing that there is an undiscovered
massive object
located beyond the boundaries of the
kuiper belt
data collection is underway and its
results will either confirm or repudiate
these assumptions even though sedna is
listed in nasa's programme of the solar
system exploration
no spacecraft is planned to be sent to
it in the nearest decades
perhaps it'll be paid due scientific
attention when the distance between
the dwarf planet and the earth is
considerably smaller
sedna may well be a really remote
celestial object
but there are some even further than
that out there in the solar system
for example the object 2018 ag-37
also known as far far out was spotted
astronomical units away from the sun
it is the remotest object in the solar
system that can be observed directly
interestingly while following their
orbits
some celestial objects already known to
us may recede from the sun much
further for example the aphelion of the
comet c1992
j1 spotted by david rabinowitz in 1992
is 3650 astronomical units
this means that it will take 78 000
years to complete a full orbit
there are many comets of this kind with
elongated orbits
and a mind-boggling orbital period that
are still
waiting to be discovered who knows
one of you might be able to do that at
some point
generally speaking celestial bodies with
such parameters fall into the category
of interstellar objects
interestingly they're usually not
gravitationally dependent on any star
and are quite free to choose their own
course
in theory such space wanderers may come
from asteroid belts of other stellar
systems
and then after they collide with a
larger object
their orbits may change this makes them
break away from their native systems
the same mechanism of producing
interstellar space objects
is applicable to our system too the
greater number of bodies from the old
cloud and the kuiper belt
eventually end up in interstellar space
bearing this in mind it seems reasonable
to assume that there is a much greater
number of objects in our system
that originally come from somewhere in
deep space than thought earlier
for example on rare occasions
interstellar interlopers may be captured
by the gravitational pull of a larger
celestial body
then they may be influenced by the sun's
gravity that will lock them on a
heliocentric orbit
the only closest planet able to perform
this on account of its impressive mass
is jupiter it is in the environs of this
gas giant that a comet can be found
which is one of the most unusual short
period comets
ever detected in the solar system
spotted on the 12th of may 1986
the comet was dubbed 96 pm mack holds
one
the object's peculiar characteristics
are its most unique features
to start with the comet's orbit is
exceptionally elongated
which allows it to approach the sun as
close as .123
astronomical units just to compare
this is two and a half times smaller
than mercury's perihelion
its chemical composition is another of
its unusual characteristics
it contains 72 times less cyanogen
than any regular comet these properties
give astronomers grounds to suppose that
mcholz1 was born
far away from the boundaries of our
system having been captured by jupiter's
gravity
it was indeed brought into heliocentric
orbit
nevertheless mack holtz one remains a
hypothetical interstellar interloper
whose origins are in essence quite
untraceable today
meanwhile there are thousands of comets
and asteroids already known to us
and among them there are some
astronomical bodies that have arrived to
our system comparatively recently
one of these is the comet known as 2i
borisov whizzing through our system at
30 kilometers per second
this object is gravitationally
independent from the sun
the comet 2i borisov is likely to have
set out on its long journey from the
cassiopeia constellation near the border
with the perseus constellation
there are several points in space that
claim the title of the comet's parent
stellar systems
ros 573 gj4384
and hd 34327
as for the comet's characteristics that
have been found out so far
its diameter measures 20 kilometers and
its orbit is hyperbolic
at the same time the comet's spectrum is
very similar to that of most other
comets in the solar system
the celestial object is consistently
observed
two consecutive flares were registered
on 2i borisov in early march
2020 by astronomers from the ogle
project team
the processes suggested by these
telltale manifestations
are indicative of an explosion in the
comet's interior
with a large fragment ejected as a
result
however nothing is known about what
happened to the newly formed
chunk even in spite of the uniqueness of
the comet
2i borisov it is quite logical that such
like celestial objects
do exist sooner or later an object like
that was supposed to pass through our
system
but it is hardly possible to say so
about another celestial body we'll be
looking at
namely about the first interstellar
asteroid
ever detected dubbed omo amur
the asteroid was detected on the 19th of
october 2017
by the canadian astronomer robert
werwick the object was 30 million
kilometers away from the earth at that
time
at first omuamur was mistaken for a
comet
but later it was reclassified as another
kind of celestial body
a hyperbolic asteroid it is highly
likely that the starting point for the
object's travels was an environs of the
vegas star
and then it set out towards our system
following a hyperbolic trajectory and
moving at a speed
of 26 kilometers per second
scientists cannot say how long aomo may
have been racing through interstellar
space
and for all we know the solar system may
be the first planetary system the
asteroid has visited
after its ejection from the parent
system
the object is posited to consist
predominantly of rock
and its diameter is estimated at
approximately 200 meters being cigar
shaped the asteroid may rightfully be
called one of the most
elongated objects in the solar system
according to the astronomer david jewett
it is a shape that mainly draws
scientists attention
the reason for that is that a celestial
object with such peculiar looks
must have some unique story of its
origin having formed either as a result
of a destructive event
or else artificially for example
at some point of its existence omuamua
may have been a shard of a
protoplanetary body
with the latter having approached its
native star too close
and ultimately having been torn apart by
its tidal forces
computer modeling of such events
revealed that there is a large celestial
body within several hundred thousand
kilometers from its star
it may really be destroyed under the
influence of stellar tidal flows
this makes it disintegrate into
exceptionally elongated
bits whose kinetic energy allows them to
leave their system
this event is thought to have happened
approximately 45 million years ago
this spurred some scientists to put
forward another hypothesis
they maintained that in theory this
object might actually turn out to be a
spaceship
constructed by an alien race to
futurologists deep regret
astronomers closed the case in 2019
proving once and for all that there is
absolutely no evidence in support of the
hypothesis
that omuamua was created artificially
at the moment the asteroid is on an
escape trajectory from our solar system
heading towards the pegasus
constellation the velocity at which it
is racing away from the sun
has proved to be slightly higher than
had been predicted by applying celestial
mechanics laws
the value reached around 31.6 kilometers
per second
on the 1st of june 2018
hypothetically it will be possible to
send a mission to this asteroid
this would allow us to find out more
about its properties
however no existing spacecraft would be
able to catch up with omuamur
as the speed at which it is streaking
through space is too high
in theory it is feasible to get close to
the asteroid after a gravity boost
maneuver
performed near jupiter and thanks to the
oberth effect
which is supposed to greatly boost the
engine's acceleration
more advanced options for the purpose
are considered as well
among these scientists suggest using a
laser pushed light sail based on the
breakthrough star shard technology
however it should be noted that the main
challenge that will have to be tackled
in the course of the missions
will be to reach the asteroid in as
little time as possible
while at the same time to be able to
collect valuable scientific data
if on the other hand the spacecraft
accelerates too much
it will not go into omar moore's orbit
and will simply whip past
it and fly on and so today
investigating the asteroid with the help
of spacecraft remains just a theory
if a mission of this sort does get
launched sometime
it is hard to imagine what secrets
lurking in the celestial body may be
revealed to us
having negotiated millions of kilometers
on their travels
objects like omuamua are bound to be
sources of staggering amounts of
valuable information
no one can tell what events they may
bear traces of
in addition to that interstellar
interlopers may in theory turn out to be
the carriers of varieties of matter
which are unknown to us
if mankind is able to reach the surface
of one of these objects
a mission like that might well find
answers to many questions
about these mysterious celestial
travelers
shortly before halloween in 2020 nasa
compiled a list of the most
terrifying worlds among others they
included
six exoplanets each of these objects
environments
is not just extremely harsh for any
living organism
even finding oneself in their
comparatively close proximity
may prove to be fatal the first object
on the list is a black gas
giant designation tres 2b
this celestial object orbits the star
tres 2
which is a yellow dwarf lying as far as
718 light years away from us
let's take a closer look at it due to
some unique properties of the chemical
composition of the surface of tres 2b
the planet absorbs over 99 percent of
all the light shed on it
the nature of these properties remains a
mystery
and chances are there are some chemical
reactions taking place on the surface
that we have never registered on any
similar object before
and it is these properties that make
tres 2b the darkest
exoplanet on the astronomical map of
today
this gas giant was discovered on the
21st of august 2006
with more details on its characteristics
obtained several years later
the mass of tres 2b is 1.2 jupiter
masses
and its radius measures 1.27 times that
of jupiter
the atmosphere is as scorching as 1000
degrees celsius which gives the
exoplanet
a faint red glow like that of ambis
still in spite of its gloomy looks tres
2b doesn't really qualify to be called
the most dangerous place in the universe
there are many more objects lurking in
space that are more terrifying than that
let's see some more inhospitable ones
here is another exoplanet designation 55
cancri e
it lies in the system of a sun-like star
designation 55 cancri a
this celestial object was discovered on
the 30th of august 2004
by the doppler spectroscopy method let's
look at it in more detail
the planet's mass equals approximately 8
earth masses
and its radius measures 1.875
that of the earth 55
cancri e is tidally locked and so it is
always daytime on one side
and night time on the other that is why
the side facing the host star is always
heated up to a temperature reaching 2400
degrees celsius
with the temperature on the night side
1300 degrees celsius
these values are so high because the
distance between the planet and its
parent star is just 0.0183 astronomical
units
besides volcanism on 55 cancri e
which is thought likely to be there
causes dust clouds emissions
these clouds trap hate and effectively
prevent it from escaping into space
the planet's orbital period is slightly
under 18 hours
as for the atmospherical makeup there is
helium and hydrogen registered in it
there are also large amounts of carbon
incidentally
this element is likely to form thick
layers of graphite and diamonds in the
planet's interior
55 cancri e isn't the only object in the
planetary system of its host star
there are four other celestial objects
orbiting it
the environments on these are by far
more hospitable
which is the feature by which the 55
cancri a
system differs from the following object
it is dubbed poltergeist or psr 1257
plus 12c
this is an exoplanet lying in a pulsar
system
the celestial object is located just
0.36
astronomical units from the system's
center
this shows that poltergeist wouldn't
have survived a supernova
that must have taken place before the
pulsar had been formed
consequently the exoplanet is likely to
have formed after this tremendous event
with the material for it coming from the
nebula left after the explosion
according to another hypothesis the
pulsar may have formed after the merging
of two white dwarfs
unlike with a supernova this process
isn't always accompanied by a powerful
blast
still as this is the first object of its
kind we have discovered
science cannot give a definite answer as
to its origins
the system with a celestial object lies
300 light years from the earth its mass
is approximately four times that of our
planet
as for its orbital period it is around
66 days
incidentally the outstandingly powerful
radiation
emitted by the pulsar is enough to
crumple any spaceship
wanting to approach the mysterious
exoplanet in its system
even with all these properties taken
into account portuguese
does not really qualify as the most
dangerous exoplanet known to us
on approaching it an astronomical body
may simply get destroyed
but it would get positively vaporized in
close proximity to the following object
the reason for this effect is the
extremely high temperature on kepler-70b
which is the hottest exoplanet known to
us
the object orbits the sub-dwarf star
kepler-70
with a surface temperature higher than
that on our sun
it reaches 6800 degrees celsius
the object's mass equals 0.44
earth masses and its radius measures
0.76 that of the earth
the celestial object's orbital period is
345 minutes
in other words a day here is less than 6
hours long
interestingly the exoplanet regularly
passes another object in the system
kepler-70c at a distance of 240
000 kilometers to date this is the
closest
that planets in space have been
registered to pass each other
the extremely high temperature on
kepler-70b could be accounted for by the
fact that this
object may once have been part of its
parent star
as for giving it the status of an
exoplanet it will take
more evidence to confirm that it
deserves to be given it
so this remains an open question
it should be mentioned that kepler-70b
is not the only celestial object we know
of
that interacts with its parent star so
closely
another object in similar conditions is
the exoplanet
known as wasp 12b this celestial body
lies
870 light years away from our system
its radius measures 1.93 times that of
jupiter
and its mass equals 1.46 jupiter masses
wasp 12b is just 0.03 astronomical units
away from its parent star
due to this close proximity the
exoplanet has a temperature reaching as
much as 2200 degrees celsius
the host star's extremely powerful
gravitation slowly absorbs wasp-12b
eventually in approximately 10 million
years time
the exoplanet is expected to be
destroyed completely
bearing all this in mind we will
probably never delve any deeper into the
nature of this exoplanet
it would appear that studying worlds of
this kind cannot be high on scientists
list of priorities
however some of these objects may happen
to have some really unique features
seemingly quite plain and ordinary
worlds like that may conceal many more
dangers than would appear at first
glance
when flying past the celestial body
hd189733b for example
one might complacently think it a safe
planet as it resembles our earth by its
looks
but if one were to get as low as the
level of its atmosphere
one would be exposed to some
life-threatening dangers
for a start the object's winds carry
particles of silicate
and develop velocities of 8 700
kilometers per hour
besides the rains on this planet cause
precipitations of molten glass
the reasons for such hazardous weather
conditions are extremely high
temperatures and the atmosphere's
peculiar chemical composition
speaking about the exoplanet's orbital
period it is approximately
2.5 days and it is highly likely that
the object is tidally locked to its
parent star
[Music]
as usual a quick overview of its main
characteristics
hd189733 is a bright blue gas giant
orbiting an orange dwarf in the
constellation vulpecula
it lies just 63 light years away from
our system
the object's diameter is 1.1 times that
of jupiter and as for its mass
it is 113 percent that of jupiter
interestingly the distance between
hd189733b
and its star is 30 times less than the
distance between the earth and the sun
and equals approximately 5 million
kilometers
due to its close proximity to the parent
star it has a constant
surface temperature of as high as around
930 degrees celsius on the dayside
with the temperature on the night side
never dropping below 425 degrees
celsius immediately on being discovered
the celestial body became a subject of
investigations
in 2007 thanks to data obtained by the
hubble telescope
scientists found out that hd189733b
has a foggy atmosphere interestingly
when the planet transits between the
observer on the earth and its star
its atmosphere assumes a reddish hue
this effect could possibly be caused by
the haze in the atmosphere
according to preliminary estimates it
consists of particles of iron
silicates and aluminium oxide
apart from that the information beamed
back by the hubble telescope
helped scientists establish that the
planet's atmosphere contains water vapor
neutral oxygen and an organic methane
compound
additional investigations revealed the
presence of carbon monoxide on the day
side of the planet
what prompted most questions however was
the results of investigations revealing
traces of methane of an unusual variety
in the planet's atmosphere
this chemical element was shown to be in
a peculiar fluorescent state
when it emits electromagnetic radiation
in the infrared range
this state of the substance is
indicative of some unknown activity in
the atmosphere of the exoplanet
which still remains to be found out
this is quite a clear-cut example of a
situation
when investigating an object like an
exoplanet with an exceptionally harsh
environment
may yield unexpected results about some
processes
taking place there that will be a
valuable contribution to science
and as the process of studying these
worlds continues
they will remain no other than horror
planets to us
as well as a solid reminder that we're
more than just lucky to be the dwellers
of our earth
temperatures of any star's interiors are
incredibly high
it is hardly surprising as thermonuclear
synthesis
that is the main energy source of all
stars can take place
only in these extreme conditions when
two atoms of hydrogen merge
they produce an atom of helium and
release an electron and several
neutrinos
in addition a great amount of energy is
released during the process
still the hydrogen helium synthesis
isn't the only process that heats up
stars
at higher temperatures other elements
may take part in chemical reactions as
well
for example lithium carbon or oxygen
in this case cause of heavier elements
are produced
such as sulfur magnesium or phosphorus
their charge is higher and they repel
each other more robustly
much more energy is needed to overcome
this resistance
when a main sequence star depletes most
of its hydrogen supply
it starts to expand and cool off
with time it ends up as a red giant
it will continue to burn due to
thermonuclear reactions of helium
transforming into carbon and oxygen
the lighter the star however the less
time it will continue to burn
eventually becoming unstable it sheds
its outer layers and goes supernova
this leaves it a white dwarf with no
resources to fuel
any thermonuclear reactions anymore
with all its energy sources depleted it
is forced to gradually cool off
interestingly when the mass of a star is
higher than a certain value
heavy thermonuclear synthesis may become
the star's main energy source
even after all hydrogen has been used up
such celestial objects are referred to
as wolfray at stars
this class of space objects was
discovered back in 1867 by the french
astronomers charles wolf
and george reyette the scientists
attention was scored by anomalously
bright emission lines of heavy elements
in these stars spectra
as for the inner makeup of these unusual
celestial objects
it was accounted for much later
stars of this class are generally heavy
they have quite a meager supply of
hydrogen
and are in the final stages of their
revolution
wolfrey had stars are extremely rare to
date
just a few hundred of them have been
discovered in our galaxy
as for their overall count in the milky
way it is estimated that there can't be
over two thousand
celestial objects of this class
wolf read stars are subdivided into
three main sequences
depending on the prevalent elements in
the spectrum
nitrogen carbon and oxygen sequences
each of them in its turn is subdivided
into several types
as for the hottest star in the studied
universe
it falls into the category of the oxygen
spectral sequence ones
the celestial body which is now known as
wr102
was discovered back in 1971
at first it was mistaken for the optical
counterpart of the x-ray source
gx3 plus one however
further observations revealed that there
were two completely different
objects according to data
acquired thanks to spectral analysis the
discovered star had unusually bright
oxygen lines in its radiation spectrum
thus in 1982 wr102
and four more bright stars became the
first to form a new class
spectral analysis showed that the star's
surface temperature reaches
over 210 000 kelvin this makes
wr102 approximately 36 times as hot as
our sun
the luminosity of the scorching hot
object is unbelievable
it is estimated at over 380
000 times that of the sun
wr 102 lies about 10 000 light years
away
the star is located in the part of the
sky with the constellation sagittarius
incidentally in spite of its
exceptionally high luminosity
it can't be seen with the naked eye as
it is too far away from us
wr-102 currently belongs to the
extremely rare star class
wo2 containing great amounts of oxygen
and almost no hydrogen it mainly relies
on the merging of heavy cores of such
elements as neon
carbon and oxygen as its sources of
energy
to date only nine objects of this class
have been discovered
with four of them located in the milky
way and the other five in other galaxies
there are two factors that make oxygen
spectral sequence stars rare
firstly there are very few of
woolfreyad's stars around because
only stars were the mass not less than
40 solar masses are potential candidates
to become ones
secondly this class represents the final
stage of evolution of stars of this type
the stage may last anything from a
thousand to ten thousand years
which is mere seconds in astronomical
terms
being of comparatively modest dimensions
wr 102
is notably quite a dense star with its
radius measuring just 58 percent that of
the sun
its mass on the other hand is estimated
at 15 to 18 solar masses
on its birth it is thought to have been
as heavy as 40 to 60 solar masses
still the high temperature and robust
chemical reactions in the star's
interior cause an exceptionally powerful
stellar wind
whose particle's velocity is over 5000
kilometers per second
it takes wr 102 just a few months to
lose one
earth mass worth of material on account
of its stellar wind
at this rate of particle emission the
star is going to lose one sun mass worth
of material
in the course of 10 000 years
[Music]
there are no planets orbiting wr
but it is shrouded in a gas envelope not
dense
and exposed to powerful ultraviolet
radiation and strong stellar wind
the envelope gets contracted and ionized
which sustains its elaborate structure
of protuberances
and arches all around the star according
to a proposed theory
the gas cloud around wr102 may probably
be remnants of the former hydrogen
outer layer of the star another theory
maintains that the cloud
came to be as a result of the particle
flow emitted by the star
wr102 is not the only outstandingly
blistering place in the universe
for example wr-140
wr30a and wr93b
as well as the central star in the bug
nebula ngc 6302
are as hot as around 200 000 kelvin
some white dwarfs may have almost the
same surface temperature
however all these are no match to
neutron stars
when neutron stars are born their
temperatures may reach a staggering 100
billion kelvin
active neutrino emissions cool them off
comparatively rapidly
but either way the surface temperature
of any neutron star is never less than a
few hundred thousand
kelvin as for their cause they must
admittedly
be hotter still having said that
it is highly improbable that the
ultimate temperature record is ever
going to be beaten
according to today's cosmological
concepts the temperature of the universe
at the moment of the hypothetical big
bang was approximately 1.4 times
10 to the power of 32 kelvin a
fundamental physical constant
this value is referred to as the planck
temperature
contemporary physics is not capable of
defining a substance of a higher
temperature
as physical laws are distorted beyond
any recognition in such incredibly harsh
conditions
quite beyond our imagination
getting back to wr 102 judging by the
data we have on stellar evolution today
this star is in its autumn years now as
opposed to main sequence stars
will reyad's stars do not expand in
their final stages of life
their substantial mass holds all the
star's material together
in a dense and hot ball however after
losing a lot of its mass through stellar
wind
the object will eventually get
destabilized
if current estimates are accurate wr102
appears to be ready to go supernova at
any point in the next 1500 years
bearing in mind that the distance
between the star and the earth is 10
000 light years it is highly likely that
the event has already taken place
a supernova would have been accompanied
by an extra powerful
gamma-ray flare fortunately our planet
is too far away to suffer any pernicious
effects of this dangerous emission
wr102 is comprised of rather heavy
chemical elements
and even iron its later evolution will
force it to contract to a critical point
the great explosion bringing the star's
life cycle to a close
will unleash processes of robust proton
and neutron capture
this way still heavier elements form
including transuranium ones
eventually wr 102 will be replaced by a
neutron star
a celestial body unbelievably hot and
dense
the former star's outer layers disrupted
by the explosion
will form a nebula slowly cooling off
it will give off heat to the space
around it
many billions of years later this
material will be able to form a new
planetary system
this is the way the large-scale
evolution of the universe occurs
supernova events release amounts of new
elements
enabling new planets asteroids and
comets to get born
these astronomical bodies form elaborate
systems bound by gravity
the elements making them up mutually
react to produce
infinite diversity of chemical compounds
that is why the cognition of the
universe is really and truly
quite endless
the exact number of galaxies in the
universe is not known for certain yet
it is supposedly well over several
hundred billion
galaxies may be of all sorts of
different shapes
as for the main varieties they include
elliptical
spiral lenticular and irregular galaxies
there are sub-categories for these as
well the milky way for example
is a barred spiral galaxy
since any galaxy consists of a great
number of stars
these objects masses may reach
incredible values
the mass of the dwarf galaxy segway 2
for example
is just 550 000 times that of the sun
as for the supergiant elliptical galaxy
ic1101
it is 1700 times heavier than the milky
way
together with its immediate neighbors
our galaxy comprises what is known as
the local group
it includes over 50 galaxies three of
which
are quite large in comparison to the
others
these are the milky way the andromeda
galaxy and the triangulum galaxy
the diameter of the local group measures
approximately 10 million light years
and its mass is about 3 trillion times
that of the sun
together with a few other galaxy
clusters of more modest dimensions
the local group in its turn comprises
the local sheet
a flat cloud with a diameter measuring
approximately 23 million light years
it is about 5 million light years thick
the local sheet forms part of the virgo
supercluster
a vast element of the large-scale
structure of the universe
the local group is conditionally divided
into four parts
the first one is the subgroup of the
milky way
comprised of our galaxy and its
satellites which may be either dwarf
galaxies
or star clusters the milky way is the
second largest galaxy in the cluster
according to today's estimates it
contains 200 to
400 billion stars as well as from 25 to
100 billion brown dwarfs
our galaxy has a spiral structure and
appears to be a disc
with a diameter measuring about 200 000
light years
at the same time its thickness is just
around a thousand light years
still there is a bulge at the center of
the disc with a diameter of around 27
000 light years a supermassive black
hole with a mass of as much as 4.3
million times that of the sun
is supposedly concealed inside the bulge
a smaller black hole is said to be
orbiting it whose mass
is anything from one to ten thousand
times that of the sun
it is positive that it is dark matter
that accounts for most of the mass of
the milky way
which is why it is impossible to
estimate it at this point
according to the latest estimates
however the mass of our galaxy is
approximately 1.5
trillion times that of the sun
going slightly further from the milky
way we can observe its 31 satellites
these are mostly irregular shaped dwarf
galaxies
they get so twisted and bent in every
which way on account of the
gravitational
influence of their massive neighbor our
closest satellite
is the dwarf galaxy cma dwarf which can
be found in the canis major
constellation
it lies 25 000 light years away from the
earth
and 42 000 light years from the center
of our galaxy
appearing like an elongated ellipsis
this dwarf galaxy
contains supposedly around 1 billion
stars
most of which are red giants
due to the gravitational influence
exerted by the milky way
the canis major galaxy has almost broken
apart
tidal forces had the following
disrupting effect
the stars torn out from the galaxy came
to form the so-called monocerous ring
an elaborate ring-shaped structure that
traps around the milky way unfortunately
observation of cma dwarf is greatly
thwarted by gas
and dust clouds floating between the
galaxy and our earth
the largest satellite of the milky way
and the fourth largest galaxy in the
local group
is the large magellanic cloud it is
located
as far as about 163 000 light years
containing approximately 30 billion
stars
it has a diameter of just seven times as
little as that of our galaxy
at the same time the cloud's mass is 300
times as little as that of the milky way
the explanation for such a stark
contrast is this
the large magellanic cloud does not
happen to contain a supermassive
black hole in the center besides there
are great amounts of dark matter in the
milky way's galactic halo
the large magellanic cloud is an sbm
type
which is in between dwarf spiral and
irregular galaxies
even though the gravitational influence
exerted over it by its massive neighbors
has as well as erased almost all traces
of its former spiral structure
the bar in the center remains to be
clearly distinguishable
there are a few especially notable
objects located in the large magellanic
cloud
for example the star r136a1
lying 165 000 light years away
is the heaviest star ever detected
this blue supergiant's mass is 315 times
that of the sun
and its surface temperature is as
scorching as over 40
000 kelvin the luminosity of r136a1
is 8.7 million times that of the sun
the large magellanic cloud is also home
to one of the largest stars in the
investigated parts of the universe
the diameter of the red giant woh g64
is over one and a half thousand that of
the sun
this is just 25 percent less than the
diameter of the largest supergiant ever
detected
stevenson 2-18 according to today's
accepted concept of stellar evolution
wohg 64
is currently in the final stage of its
life and is expected to go supernova at
any moment in the next several thousand
years
when speaking about the milky way
subgrip of course we can't but mention
the virgo stellar stream
occupying approximately five percent of
the entire sky
it appears as an exceptionally scattered
and dim flow
of several hundred thousand stars on the
outskirts of our galaxy
according to the overwhelming majority
of scientists the virgo stellar stream
is remnants of a dwarf spherical galaxy
that has at some point almost completely
been swallowed up by the milky way
moving yet further we will soon
encounter the galaxy known as andromeda
or the andromeda nebula together with
its satellites it forms part of the
local group referred to as the andromeda
subgrip the galaxy lies as far as around
800 kilopasc
or two and a half million light years we
transit the status of our closest
neighboring galaxy
which isn't a dwarf one
diameter of the andromeda nebula
measures approximately 220
000 light years which is slightly more
than that of the milky way
with its star count of around a trillion
there are three to five
times as many of them in it as there are
in our galaxy
interestingly the masses of the two
galaxies are more or less the same
at around one and a half trillion solar
masses
the point is that the stars forming the
andromeda nebula
are an average elder and lighter than
those of the milky way
andromeda is one of our closest
neighbours
appearing as an elongated light spot it
is also one of the few
galaxies visible to the naked eye
interestingly
its angular diameter is six times that
of the moon
the andromeda nebula is a spiral galaxy
with two clearly defined arms
it is peculiar for its binary core
when we observe it through a telescope
we notice two clearly seen star clusters
in the center of the galaxy
with a distance between them around five
light-years
according to one of proposed theories at
some point
andromeda swallowed up another galaxy
capturing its core
another supposition has it that there is
after all just one core
with some part of it obscured by a dust
cloud
it is estimated that the overall mass of
the central part of this galaxy
is over 140 million solar masses
there are approximately 400 globular
clusters in the andromeda nebula
which is about two to three times as
many as the rye in the milky way
this means that it probably swallowed up
quite a few dwarf galaxies in the past
and the clusters it contains now
are the remnants of their cores
andromeda has around
30 satellites the ones that stand out
are dwarf spiral galaxies designations
m32 and
m110 some theories suggest
that m32 round the andromeda nebula
several billion years ago
leaving a gargantuan hole in its
structure
this had a serious effect on m32 as well
with a substantial part of this galaxy
becoming andromeda's galactic halo
the milky way is estimated to collide
with andromeda in around
5 billion years time today it is still
quite impossible to model this
tremendous encounter and its
consequences accurately
but it is bound to be a truly
spectacular sight
the third large representative of the
local group is the triangulum galaxy
it is twice as little as the milky way
in size
and has no confirmed satellites but some
dwarf galaxies of the local group
may well be gravitationally bound to it
the triangulum galaxy is not likely to
boast a supermassive black hole in its
center
the diameter of the galaxy measures
approximately 50 000 light years
the distance between triangulum and the
milky way is 2.7 to 3 million light
years
the galaxy also contains the ngc 604
nebula
which is the largest known area in space
where stars are actively born
the stellar nursery's diameter reaches 1
300 light years around 200
supergiants with a total mass of a
hundred thousand
solar masses are compactly grouped here
these stars are young and hot with their
powerful luminosity ionizing the gas the
star cluster is enveloped in
this gives the gas a bright glow which
in its turn makes the nebula appear
quite bright
apart from the objects mentioned there
are other ones in the local group
which don't fall into any of the
mentioned subgroups
as a rule these are remote dwarf
galaxies and star clusters
not tightly gravitationally bound to any
of the three large galaxies
the galaxy ic-10 can be singled out here
lying approximately 2.2 million light
years away from the sun
it is the only galaxy of the local group
where stars are actively born
ic10 is shrouded in a hydrogen outer
envelope
whose radius is much bigger than that of
the galaxy itself
the stellar disk of ic10 meanwhile
rotates in the direction
opposite to that of the outer envelope
with their mind-boggling dimensions of
hundreds of thousands of light years on
end
even the largest galaxies remain tiny
dots
in the large-scale structure of the
universe the distances between them are
staggeringly enormous
and even light takes millions of years
to reach the closest of them
nevertheless we can still observe and
study them
there are innumerable riddles lurking in
the cosmos
and mankind keeps solving them one after
another without flagging zest
because every new discovery is just
another step
in our cognition of the universe
the places we've just seen are
admittedly just a tiny portion
of all the staggering diversity of the
space objects known to us
if we ever managed to explore them all
the list will stretch across quite a
number of documentaries
by taking small steps we will slowly but
surely
bring the astronomical map of the areas
of space comparatively close to us
to a whole new level and with every new
celestial body
added on this map the picture of the
universe
is growing ever more appealing
[Music]
you